those are some of the latest beats from
the streets of philadelphia where a
group of budding artists
decided to start their own record label
while still in high school
it's part of a new push by the city
school district to make arts education
more practical
christina raffini caught up with the
high school friends
as they were about to release their
latest single
they don't yet have the fame and the
group doesn't actually have a name
but these philly teens do have a record
label
and a producer 18 year old caleb autry
i originally wanted to be an engineer
but i realized quickly that it wasn't
for me
i knew i had a passion for music and i
was just scared to pursue it
[Music]
that changed last february when his math
and science focused high school george
washington carver
became the test site for the
philadelphia school district's new music
production program
from audio engineering to marketing and
distribution
it teaches kids the business behind the
beat
why is it important that this program
teaches you not just how to make the
record
but the business part of the music
industry as well young artists
going into the music industry today
they're often getting taken advantage of
that's something that i have a goal of
changing and i feel like kids learning
that
in school is going to help with that
caleb grew up playing drums and piano
but he gravitated towards producing is
he a good producer is he means
he definitely challenged me i mean i can
kick him out of the road
he laid down some loops and collaborated
with other students on the lyrics and
vocals
they put their heart in it and you could
hear it on the track but
but heart can only take you so far which
is why a professional music producer
andy hurwitz
who volunteers with the program
suggested the students start their own
record label
he and carver high school alum omyron
devine pope who runs a branding business
help teach the budding moguls how to
merchandise their melodies
everything that we're touching designing
is top to bottom
carvers students to carver alum down to
the t-shirts and everything
they call the label what else carver
records
when they played me the music i was
shocked and so i sent it out to a couple
people in the industry
i didn't say this is a high school
project i'm working on you just sent it
to him
like what do you think of this yeah and
then he's like can we sign them i'm like
well they're in high school he's like oh
we are definitely going to do this the
crew doesn't have a recording contract
yet but by the end of summer they plan
to release
three singles and an album does this
kind of change your trajectory
i feel like it opened my eyes to the
possibilities of the music business
it also earned caleb a full scholarship
to study the industry
at drexel university this fall what's
the feeling you get when you hear
this single finished it's just like wow
all the hard work we put in this just
all came together maybe the fame
won't be too far off
for cbs this morning christina rothini
philadelphia
now we want to know the name of that
song yes caleb
the group doesn't even have a name yet i
love it i love the logo carver records
but i love what they're doing and how
they're doing it
you can see their passion and enthusiasm
and not for nothing they're good
yeah they are and they're giving me the
new edition fields right caleb
18 years old he did he producer
yeah i like that i like that little
motto their heart can only take you so
far
that is so true right